dépouillement le nevada tout d'abord où
joe biden sans avoir alors qu il l
avantage le wisconsin avantage également
à joe biden le michigan
avantage à joe dalton même si c'est un
avantage extrêmement serrée pour le
moment les derniers dépouillement
données 49,5 pour joe biden contre 48,9
% pour donald trump la caroline du nord
avantage en revanche au candidat
républicain c'est que la géorgie ou
donald trump à a également un avantage
la pennsylvanie on vous en parle
évidemment depuis le début de cet état
extrêmement important et bien c'est un
avantage à trump mais grosse incertitude
car un million de votes par
correspondance restent à dépouiller je
vous propose justement d'écouter le
gouverneur de pennsylvanie qui
s'exprimait ce matin sur ce
dépouillement il promet une forme de
démocratie que tous ces votes seront
comptés il tient à être rassurant
écoutez nous ne connaîtrons peut-être
même pas les résultats aujourd'hui
mais le plus important est que nous
ayons des résultats fiables
encore une fois même si cela prend un
peu plus de temps que ce à quoi nous
sommes habitués
ne vous y trompez pas notre démocratie
est mise à l'épreuve dans cette élection
voilà la pennsylvanie donc il ne devrait
pas faire connaître ses résultats
aujourd'hui il faudra encore pas mal de
temps pour dépouiller ac 1 million de
ventes en tout cas sachez une chose il
semblerait si nos calculs sont bons que
si joe biden l'emportent au wisconsin où
vichy gagnent et dans le nevada
il pourrait éventuellement justement se
passer d'une victoire en pennsylvanie à
noter que le vote par correspondance ans
fm un million de votes par
correspondance qui restent à dépouiller
sont en général ou buts ont
traditionnellement à gauche puisque les
électeurs républicains se sont souvent
davantage déplacé en personne dans les
dans les bureaux de vote
en tout cas un constat stéphanie
aujourd'hui c'est une bataille féroce
entre les deux camps à coups de
déclarations interposées
ah ben oui ça il fallait s'en douter
olivier ça a débuté hier soir on va
essayer d'être chronologique avec donald
trump aux alentours de deux heures du
matin ici aux etats unis le président
qui a revendiqué la victoire dénonçant
des fraudes massives il a demandé le
recompte des votes menaçant de saisir la
cour suprême le camp d'aïda nuit n'était
pas en reste
il a aussi communiqué joe biden
dénonçant des propos scandaleux sans
précédent joe biden qui lui aussi a
revendiqué une forme de victoire et
s'est montré très optimiste sur sa
victoire à cette élection présidentielle
la bataille des déclarations a fait
ensuite une petite pause pendant
certainement quelques heures de sommeil
pour les deux candidats et puis à donald
trump a rouvert les hostilités ce matin
sur son compte twitter alors là c'est
important je fais une petite parenthèse
quand même assez cocasse à noter que la
plupart de ces tweets ce matin trois sur
quatre ont été censurés par le réseau
social je cite au motif que le contenu
est contestée est susceptible d'être
trop peur donald trump en tout cas qui
s'est étonné que l' avantage soit donné
ce matin à bail d'un écouté hier soir
j'étais en tête souvent bien parti dans
de nombreux états clés dans presque tous
les endroits dirigé et contrôlé par des
démocrates
puis un par un ils ont commencé à
disparaître comme par magie au fur et à
mesure que les bulletins de vote
surprise était content et très étrange
et les sondeurs se sont complètement est
historiquement tromper
est à noter que donald trump a justement
demandé tout à l'heure le décompte total
des votes dans le wisconsin qui semble
justement acquise à joe biden le
candidat démocrate de son côté n'est
évidemment pas après lui non plus à
lâcher quoi que ce soit il a aussi
communiqué par tweets se met à écouter
nous n'aurons pas de répit tant que le
vote de chacun n'aura pas été comptés
soyez à l'écouté de ma directrice de
campagne
jane au mali dillon et mon conseiller de
campagne bob bauer qui font le point sur
la situation de la course
alors évidemment cette bataille
s'annonce ardue rond l'aura bien compris
elle pourrait se terminer devant les
tribunaux de toute façon donald trump
eux avaient déjà prévenu qui craignait
des fraudes massives il faut savoir
qu'aux états unis ce sont les tribunaux
des états fédérés qui vont être
compétent dans ce domaine s'il ya une
contestation de leurs décisions et bien
ce sera après au congrès d'agir et la
cour suprême pourrait ainsi se saisir on
se souvient en 2007 bataille entre al
gore et de george bush notamment en
floride qui portait sur quelques voix
george bush avait alors demandé le
recomptage des votes
finalement al gore avait renoncé
à saisir les tribunaux essai de george
bush qui avait remporté la victoire
merci beaucoup stéphanie pour ces
précisions stéphanie vous restez avec
nous pour décrypter avec nos invités à
les dernières actualités de cette
élection présidentielle pleine de
rebondissements le sort du scrutin
désormais suspendu à six et à près de 24
heures après la fermeture des bureaux de
vote les états unis ne connaissent donc
toujours pas le nom de leur nouveau
président et le monde entier retient son
souffle et guettent le nom du futur
locataire de la maison blanche
là ça notre décryptage avec nos invités
pour parler de ce scrutin très serré et
avec nous ce soir yannick mireur
politologue spécialiste des états unis
bonsoir à vos côtés à nicolas conques et
membres des républicains overseas france
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors avantage à joe biden
ce soit en terme de grands électeurs six
états cependant n'ont pas encore donné
leur résultat dans la pennsylvanie une
journée pleine de rebondissements
d'incertitude est ce que vous attendiez
à un tel scénario yannick mireur pas
vraiment on pouvait s'attendre y avait
différents scénarios qui pouvait être
logiquement
devant nous ce soir on avait pas mal
parlé aux états unis d'une vague bleue
c'était envisageable en réfléchissant la
situation
mais il n'y avait rien de certain la
meilleure preuve évidemment a été
apportée depuis ce matin puisqu'il n'y
en a pas le pire scénario c'était celui
que l'on vit au fond parce que le
troisième c'était une légère avance donc
rien n'était exclu du président sortant
savait pas non plus le cas alors donc on
se trouve est compris dans les états
bascule dont on attend des résultats
vous avez parlé du nevada notamment le
michigan et louise can see no 6 qui
depuis ce matin européennes sont en
balance en particulier où c'est
extrêmement serré au fond de la
différence se fait par quelques dizaines
ou quelques centaines de voix donc le
résultat de tout ça ça confirme d'une
part une polarisation très forte du vote
électoral aux états unis il faut encore
attendre le participation et surtout la
participation par catégories d'électeurs
et notamment sans doute le plus
intéressant sur une perspective de
génération à savoir ce que s'il ya une
forte mobilisation des 18 25 ans par
exemple ou des 18 35 si vous voulez ça
c'est une première chose qui sera
intéressant d'analyser plus tard parce
que comme partout ailleurs souvent les
électeurs plus mature les actifs et les
retraités
montrent un taux de participation plus
élevée que les autres et on sait bien
que globalement la tendance dans les
années qui viennent et déjà depuis
quelques années pour les plus jeunes
électeurs de se porter vers plus
naturellement disons vers le parti
démocrate
bon c'est un des sujets le deuxième
point je dirais c'est que l'on a
beaucoup parlé pour ceux qui
s'intéressent à ces choses-là
journalistes commentateurs politiques
des lignes de front culturel aux états
unis comme quoi pour simplifier
l'amérique démocrate serait l'amérique
des rivages de la tec de l'amérique
mondialisée l'amérique rouge
républicaine celle des grands espaces et
les catégories sociales - favoriser
voire même victime des effets de la
mondialisation et de la transformation
économique que vivent les économies
industrialisées dont les états unis au
fond
sans doute s'il ya du vrai là dedans
mais je pense aussi et surtout que ce
vote 30 au fond au delà de la
personnalité du président montre que le
souci économique auquel il est plus
volontiers associée à une meilleure
performance on va dire sur l'économie
nonobstant la situation du co lead et
bien d'économies est quand même le souci
majeur qui portent vers l'électorat
vers le vote trump et ceci peut-être
avait été négligée c'est une hérésie par
lesquels je m'explique
la résilience en dépit de toutes les
outrances et de toutes les excès
de monsieur trump qui ne représente pas
vraiment le parti républicain dans son
histoire
aujourd'hui aux états unis encore une
fois donc la préoccupation économique
compte tenu des effets de la crise
sanitaire sur l'économie américaine et
internationale
conques et l'élection de joe biden est
ce qu'elle est joué pour vous ou alors
tout peut encore basculer là ce stade
personne ne peut se prononcer il ya
encore des états pivots qui sont dans la
bascule on peut pas preuve va faire de
pronostics en faveur de l'un ou de
l'autre
hier il y avait les avancées
significatives qui mérite est de
constater une avance est de pouvoir
penser que trump allait l'emporter dans
les états du blue hole c'est à dire le
michigan le week en scène et la
pennsylvanie
au réveil les nouvelles sont un peu
autres donc on se pose des questions sur
pourquoi au michigan 130000 mode qui
arrivent et dont la totalité sont
exclusivement dédiés aux candidats
démocrates à bayonne et 00 24 heures et
du coup en parallèle de sa sur l'autre
état comme le risque en scène une légère
avance de bayonne laisse à penser qu'ils
et puis avoir les trop d qui demande
donc un recomptage des voix comme les
lois de ceux de cet état le permet alors
on va revenir justement sur ces fraudes
que dénonce donald trump tout à l'heure
mais avant je vous propose de rejoindre
stéphanie de murs eu notre envoyé
spécial à washington
stéphanie le suspense est total donald
trump eux joe biden au coude à coude
alors qu'on lise avec donald trump
allait être balayés on se souvient par
joe biden les américains se sont
déplacés en masse et ont déjoué tous les
pronostics
les sondeurs et les médias sont-ils
groggy aux etats unis aujourd'hui
eh bien écoutez il faut peut-être
distinguer justement les sondeurs et les
médias il faut être honnête autant les
médias américains on en a déjà parlé ici
étaient pour la plupart d'ailleurs les
donateurs des appels des médias
mainstream est très très partisan je
mets toujours à part évidemment fox news
qui était très pro républicain mais les
médias faisait plutôt preuve de prudence
en étant extrêmement partisan en voulant
convaincre les électeurs d'aller voter
donc il avait je vous cache pas un des
mines un peu rabougri hier sur le
plateau de cnn il faut préciser que
donald trump a quand même augmenté sa
base électorale en qu'il soit gagnant ou
perdant de cette élection c'est un fait
il a augmenté sa base et électorale il a
gagné 1,3 million de voix
supplémentaires par rapport à la
dernière élection donc pas de quoi
réjouir effectivement ces médias qui
sont sont pas cachés qui était plutôt
pro by donne les instituts de sondage et
bien c'est autre chose ils devront
certainement en tirer voilà une fois de
plus un des réflexions et une remise en
cause on rappelle que ces instituts de
sondage pour la plupart ont donné joe
biden gagnant avec plus de 10 points
d'avancé une véritable vague bleue qui
quoi qu'il arrive de toute manière
n'aura pas lieu
on se souvient en real clear politics
qui fédère tous les sondages
randonnée joe biden gagnant en floride
dans l'ohio dans le texas où finalement
il a perdu alors comment expliquer cette
non clairvoyance de ses instituts dont
c'est pourtant le métier bien beaucoup
de commentateurs ici parle du fameux
vote cacher le chayer lecteurs qui
n'osent pas dire qu'ils votent
trump on a assisté notamment une
plaidoirie hier du présentateur vedette
de fox news coeur
karlsson qui se demandait tout
simplement et ton dans un pays libre
je vous passe tous les arguments mais la
conclusion c'était bien
nous ne sommes pas aujourd'hui dans un
pays libre aux états unis selon lui une
autre illustration pendant cette
campagne qui a attiré mon attention la
démission de glen green world
c'est un journaliste assez connus qu'ils
allaient collaborer avec edward snowden
notamment et bien game will warne il a
démissionné de son média qui intercepte
parce que on lui a demandé d'être plus
clément envers les démocrates c'est lui
qu'il dit dans un dans une grande lettre
dans un grand communiqué où il se
justifie dit que les états unis
aujourd'hui et notamment la presse en
particulier sont un pays de censure donc
c'est assez intéressant toutes ces
réflexions
il ya aussi peut-être la méconnaissance
de la part des instituts des électeurs
tout simplement c'était frappant de voir
ici quand on parlait avec les chauffeurs
de taxi les serveurs dans les
restaurants toutes ces personnes nous
disait mais attendez c'est pas du tout
plié
donald trump va gagner alors il ne va
peut-être pas gagné
on le saura dans quelques heures mais en
tout cas pour ces américains dans la rue
eh bien c'était loin d'être la vague
bleue annoncé par les instituts de
sondage justement merci beaucoup
stéphanie pour toutes ces précisions
stéphanie de millau depuis washington on
vous retrouve un lors de cette édition
un peu plus tard alors yannick mireur
nicolas fouquet le disais tout à l'heure
le président sortant contexte conteste
en tout cas le dépouillement donald
trump dit que les démocrates ont triché
il est dense l'apparition de butin
surprise dans la nuit
comment vous comprenez cette posture
de donald trump yannick mireur écouter
ça ne me paraît pas correspondre ce ton
général ne paraît je dissocie écouter
assez volontiers le parti républicain
son histoire au cours des 20 dernières
années c'est un parti qui a beaucoup
évolué et plutôt dans le mauvais sens
parce qu'il n'a plus au fond de corpus
idéologique de qui si je puis dire il a
été en quelque sorte prise en otage par
ceux qui en 2016 était assez imprévu
c'est à dire l'arrivée de monsieur trump
face à des candidats plutôt assez
classique je pense en particulier à jeff
bouche et donc il a su épouser un moment
particulier c'est son talent mais on
peut pas dire il a été démocrate dans le
passé on peut pas dire que c'est un une
incarnation du persil fication une
personnification pardon du parti
républicain à travers son histoire le
parti républicain a besoin de se
réinventer
ça ne veut pas dire que les choses vont
très bien non plus du côté du parti
démocrate
plus traditionnellement traversée par
des courants mais que du coup avec ces
évolutions la et en particulier celle du
parti républicain on est dans une
situation où l'on sort d'une certaine
façon de faire de la politique qui a
toujours été quand même parfois musclées
aux états unis comme partout ailleurs
c'est bien normal
donc je suis pas très étonnée et je
trouve assez regrettable pour la vie
publique aux etats-unis ledit
médiatement s'engouffrer dans des
une approche de d'insuffler une sorte de
rumeurs et
souffler sur les braises en dix ans
alors que le dépouillement n'est pas
terminée que forcément il y aurait eu
des fraudes même si certaines choses
peuvent peut-être surprendre précisément
on attendait du dépouillement
l'ensemble du comptage or si vous avez
des voix qui n'ont pas été comptés dans
certaines parties mettront plusieurs
bennes par exemple des états bascule
vous savez bien que c'est un vote qui
est plus majoritairement démocrate en
revanche si c'est dans des zones plus
rurales on sait qu'il est plus
naturellement républicain donc je suis
pas du tout bien placé pour vous dire
s'il ya fraude ou pas fraude mais se
jeter dessus tout de suite dans un
climat qui est déjà s'est polarisée aux
états unis me paraît tout à fait
regrettable et ce n'est pas le parti
républicain que l'on a pu les analyses
des états unis ont pu admirer par le
passé ni qu'on a sorti un petit peu de
la route
nicolas conquérir le mot de la fin
effectivement quel est votre regard vous
par rapport à cette posture de donald
trump qui dénonçaient des fraudes
donald trump que vous soutenez qu'elle
aime qu'est-ce que quel est votre regard
sur sur cette posture voilà on attente
d'une part que l'ensemble des bulletins
soient comptabilisés hormis les états
pivots dont on a parlé il faut quand
même race souligné qu en arizona
cinq cent mille bulletins qui n'obtint
pas comptabilisé et qui peuvent
fortement pesé dans la balance
et ça revoir tout à fait les scénarios
et les chemins vers la victoire des uns
des autres
ça c'est très significatif et que
effectivement ça remet en question toute
cette généralisation du vote par
correspondance qui est à l'origine de ce
trouble et qui donne quand même une
image assez assez dégradantes ont fait
du traitement des bulletins et qui 24
heures après la fermeture des bulletins
des bureaux de vote qu'on ait toujours
pas de vainqueur
c'est pas c'est pas du tout satisfaisant
merci à vous nicolas conc'air membres
des rues publiques
hannover 6 france merci à vous philippe
mireur politologue spécialiste à des
états unis et jeu
propose maintenant d'aller à new york on
va retrouver notre reporter thomas
bonnin thomas vous êtes donc sur place
les autorités craignent des débordements
à l'annoncé des résultats
on est face au scénario qui était
redouté par les autorités celui où les
résultats sont contestés où aucun des
deux candidats n'étaient en mesure de
revendiquer une victoire nette et sans
appel la situation risque donc de
s'éterniser des accusations sont d'ores
et déjà échangés entre les deux
candidats la crainte maintenant c'est
que ces invectives se concrétise sur le
terrain entre des militants pro trump et
pro by donne quelques manifestations
sont d'ores et déjà prévues ce mercredi
mais il semblerait que le pays soit
suspendu à l'issue de ce scrutin
particulièrement indécis et même
l'annoncent d'un vainqueur dans les
prochaines heures ne devrait pas mettre
un terme aux débats bien au contraire
tant les résultats sont serrés dans
certains états et aussi parce qu'il ya
des accusations de dinde irrégularités
qui plane sur le décompte les barricades
ne seront pas prêts d'être retirée ici à
new york tout comme dans les autres
villes des états unis les autorités sont
sur le qui-vive beaucoup de police
locale avait anticipé en suspendant
toute demande de congé de la part de
leur effectif pour pouvoir mobiliser le
plus de policiers possible si la
situation le nécessite évidemment les
regards sont tournées maintenant vers
washington et vers la maison blanche qui
est véritablement barricadé depuis
plusieurs jours hier soir déjà quelques
dizaines dans thiva étaient présents à
proximité de l'édifice présidentiel et
l'autre crainte c'est la confrontation
armée entre les franges les plus
radicales des supporters de trump et de
by day by day est une ville cristallise
particulièrement ces craintes et la
ville de portland dans l'orégon le fbi a
indiqué suivre la situation de très près
dans cette ville qui a été secouée ces
derniers mois par des manifestations
parfois violentes
un mot enfin pour souligner cette
tension régnant ici aux etats unis c'est
le fait qu une célèbre chaîne de
supermarchés a retiré il ya quelques
jours de ses rayons les munitions et les
armes qu'on pouvait auparavant y trouver
merci beaucoup thomas pour tous ces
précisions thomas abonnés en direct 2
new york rester avec nous sur rt france
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur la situation sanitaire en france
avec des président des prévisions
toujours inquiétante pour la mi-novembre
un conseil de défense est tenue ce matin
et puis nous parlerons du projet de loi
sécurité globale débattu à partir
d'aujourd'hui à l'assemblée extension
des pouvoirs de police municipale
surveillance par des drones équipés de
caméras floutage des visages de
policiers en opération à des
propositions qui suscitent des
inquiétudes a tout de suite sur rt
france
[Musique]
oui
dans les banques où la diversité c'est
notre point fort par notre point faible
ce que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août c'est une
mobilisation sociétal qui n'existait pas
avant toutes les confessions se
retrouver sur la place des martyrs un
certain chouhada et tout le monde
discute est finalement que mon discuter
ils sont trouvés entre le même drapeau
libanais pour une fois vous voyez des
images assez touchants de l'armée qui
était presque impliqué avec les
manifestants aujourd'hui on sent que le
ton a changé c'est la poste des hommes
politiques et sont en train de manipuler
l'armée on sait très bien pourquoi ils
nous tirent dessus c'est pas s'ils
savent que c'est leur fin ils se
préparent le seul langage qu'ils
connaissaient la violence ne va pas être
violent mais on va rester
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui ai des camps dit
elvia pas d'alternative au sort du
politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï pg les jeunes
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose alors gens
font-ils
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
mais on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un en talents de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie de catastrophe
ça veut dire à côté
date à ce trop fine il ya un tournant
mais on recevait à vivre mais dans une
autre direction c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire de l'humanité que pour
sauver des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais quel d'une décision
invraisemblable pour vous ça dépend
telles valeurs on attribuait la mort la
vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie revient
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes même
individuel avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un départ
normal un débat éthique
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je suis
répand dans l'appartement on est énervé
donner le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
loin de paris mais toujours loin de ce
qu'ils y font des remarques on est passé
un tour de tracteur avec nous plaiderons
campagne il faut savoir c'est qu'une vie
différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles ma forêt t d un peu plus
aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes c'est diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
française en france lé débat sur la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence ont
repris cet après midi au lendemain d'un
vote surprise de l'opposition olivier
vers ans était quant à lui auditionné
par la mission d'information sur la
gestion et les conséquences de
l'épidémie coronavirus pour plus de
détails on va retrouver tout de suite
notre reporter estelle farges à
l'assemblée nationale et celle bonsoir
alors les députés ont donc repris les
débats sur l'état d'urgence sanitaire
oui avec 272 voix contre 108 l'assemblée
nationale a adopté la prolongation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire ce dernier
devrait donc rester en vigueur jusqu'au
16 février prochain comme le souhaitait
le gouvernement l'assemblée nationale a
donc fait table rase 1 du vote d'hier
soir des députés de l'opposition avaient
réussi à faire passer invoque le
prolongeant jusqu'au 14 décembre bien
plus tôt donc que ce que souhaitait le
gouvernement et ce pour la simple raison
qu'au moment du vote et bien la majorité
présidentielle s'est retrouvé en
minorité il n'y avait tout simplement
pas assez de députés lrm le texte
devrait donc être adoptée samedi avant
un examen au sénat ce jeudi
autre temps fort est elle aujourd'hui
assez l'audition d'olivier ferrand mois
exactement olivier pendant 2h30 olivier
aveyron a répondu aux questions à des
députés de la commission denquête
qu'ovide 19 de l'assemblée nationale le
ministre de la santé qui a été interrogé
sur de nombreux dossiers comme la
stratégie à deux tests le nombre de lits
de réanimation ou encore de possibles
erreurs d'anticipation de la deuxième
vague de kovy des 19 j'aurais pu
entendre ce reproche si nous étions
restés les bras croisés a répondu à ce
propos le ministre de la santé olivier
ferrand qui a précisé avoir toujours été
en phase avec les décisions prises sur
les textes par exemple il a expliqué les
raisons des retards dans l'obtention à
des résultats en septembre dernier il a
seul oubli souligné que le gouvernement
avait toujours
agi de manière à garantir la protection
de la population olivier aveyron qui en
début d'audition avait appelé à l'aider
puis les députés à tenir compte du
caractère évolutif de la situation et à
faire preuve d'humilité le temps
politique n'est pas le ton scientifiques
at il précisé merci beaucoup estelle
pour toutes ces précisions estelle
farges en direct de l'assemblée
nationale et on poursuit avec les
derniers chiffres du coronavirus en
france santé publique france dénombre 36
mille trois cent trente nouveaux cas de
contamination ou kobe dans 24 heures 430
personnes sont décédées à l'hôpital
c'est toujours ces dernières 24 heures
et 469 patients ont été admis en
réanimation
plus de quatre mille malades du coc u19
sont désormais en réanimation ou en
soins intensifs pour revenir sur la
situation sanitaire et sur sa gestion
nous sommes avec jérôme marty médecin
généraliste président du syndicat de
l'union française pour une médecine
libre jérôme marty merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
nouveau conseil de défense ce matin le
président a rappelé la gravité de la
situation qui continue de se dégrader
avec des services de réanimation de plus
en plus proche de la saturation avec un
patient hospitalisé en raison du coc vie
toutes les 30 secondes
en france elle est là la réalité
aujourd'hui
oui elle est là et vous l'avez justement
rappelé en montrant les chiffres de
santé publique france 4000 patients
animations sur une potentielle de simili
qu'on peut certes augmenté de 1000 ou
1500 lits mais avec difficulté donc ça
veut dire que en gros l'état 60% de nos
capacités et puis on va monter
rapidement à 80% comme dans certaines
régions île de france rhône alpes ont
été rognés déjà avec une crainte qui est
celle d'arriver à 100% donc oui oui et
le ministre des raisons d'appeler à la
raison l'ensemble des politiques je
crois qu'il faut impérativement que tout
le monde marche dans le même sens
maintenant parce que nous avons perdu
tout le temps et nous n'aurons plus
tous de temps à perdre parce que sinon
le virus gagnera alors plus de temps
donc on imagine de nouvelles mesures
durcir les mesures pour vous on attend
d'ailleurs des réponses demain un
couvre-feu en île de france par exemple
on sait que la question est sur la table
ce type de mesure ça vous semble
indispensable il faut en prendre
d'autres non je crois que c'est passé
pas la mesure indispensable ce qui est
indispensable c'est de boucher les trous
dans la raquette qu'on peut avoir dans
les zones qui ont été en quelque sorte
n'ont pas oublié les qui ont été masqués
un petit peu par une communication
gouvernementale qui a été plus sur
l'économique sur les sanitaires c'est à
dire que l'on a vu des ministres comme
elisabeth borrel qui nous ont dit qu'il
ya peu un pour cent de décontamination
qui se font à l'entreprise
on a des ministres comme le ministre des
transports qui nous a dit qu'il n'y
avait pas de contamination dans les
transports ou à michel drucker élections
nationales qui nous à kigali 0 07 % de
contamination dans les écoles tout cela
évidemment est très très très très
largement minorées et s'il ya des
mesures à prendre c'est sur ces zones là
l'entreprise l'école leleu
le primaire comme les plus grandes
sections et puis les transports c'est là
qu'il faut agir parce qu'il n'ya pas de
génération spontanée de virus dans le
cercle familial
il y à un moment où les seconds aminé on
ramène le minus dans le cercle familial
et il faut jouer sur ces zones seront
établies
vous prenez finalement pour un
confinement total comme le premier comme
ce qu'on a on a vécu en avril et mars
avril dernier je prône surtout sur un dd
télétravail qui soit véritablement
observé respecter et multiplier s'est
pas encore assez le corps plaide pour
s'il le faut si on n'est pas capable
d'organiser les classes comme il le faut
mais il faut avoir le courage pendant
quinze jours trois semaines de fermer
les écoles
et puis et puis certainement oui
durcir un petit peu les choses encore
parce que on voit bien que on est en
train d'arriver encore une fois au
maximum de nos capacités c'est ce qu'on
veut absolument éviter là encore une
fois aussi ce que vivent les commerçants
les artisans et aussi les drames
économiques et
malheureusement des fois les drames
humains parfois définitif mais pour
éviter cela aussi il faut arriver à
taper fort et le plus court possible
parce que le moins poste à risque
seraient d'abord un confinement qui dure
et qui dure de plus en plus avec des
semaines et des semaines et des semaines
parce que là on aura des drames humains
beaucoup plus nombreux et des rames
économique irréparables alors je vous
propose vous l'évoquez tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs d'écouter olivier vers ans
têtière à l'assemblée nationale à une
prise de parole remarquez on regarde et
on en parle ensuite je suis rentré dans
deux chambres dans ce service de
réanimation de corbeil-essonnes dans la
première chambre il y avait un jeune
homme de 28 ans de 28 ans en coma intubé
et ventilé avec pas loin de 10 pouces
seringue au pouvoir à la fois
l'alimenter lui fournir les médicaments
essentiels pour le maintenir en pis dans
la deuxième chambre
il y avait un homme en surpoids âgé de
35 ans c'est ça la réalité mesdames et
messieurs les députés
si vous voulez pas l'entendre certains
lycées elle est là la réalité deux
hôpitaux à l'est
nos hôpitaux c'est à la réalité nos
hôpitaux
vous êtes en train de débattre de sujets
alors que nous soyons se bat pour sauver
des vies de cette manière-là nos
hôpitaux
le ministre de la santé on le voit qui
perd son sang froid
vous comprenez ces propos les députés
selon vous ne comprennent vraiment pas
la gravité de la situation alors olivier
ferrand et est il trop alarmiste quel
est votre sentiment
je comprends l'exaspération du médecin
comme caen - l'exaspération du politique
c'est à dire qu'aux scènes de
l'assemblée nationale ne peut pas dire
aux gens de sortie qui te dirai en
quelque sorte de l'assemblée nationale
ça c'est pas possible
mais je comprends l'exaspération du
médecin qui a le droit d'être fatigué
avec tout ce qui vit mais je n'oublie
pas non plus que ce même ministre nous a
dit à une époque qu'il fallait pas
porter de masque n'oublie pas non plus
que ce ministre a dit à une époque que
la médecine de ville était absente de la
troisième phase de la première vague
donc je vous dis rien mais mais mais je
comprends cette exaspération et je
comprend l'urgence où je comprend
l'urgence
vous savez on a une équipe de france
puis tous partie de l'équipe de france
quel que soit le cojones contrôle
d'importants est là le problème c'est
qu'on a une équipe de france je disais
sur une autre chaîne où on a un coach
est inaudible
on a des joueurs qui veulent rester sur
le banc on a certains joueurs qui ne
savent même pas que le match est
aujourd'hui d'autres joueurs qui veulent
jouer mais alors faso des joueurs qui
jouent et puis grêle du jeu qui change
tout le temps donc on ne peut pas gagner
ça continue comme ça il faut couvrir
véritablement que on tire tous dans les
mêmes ça c'est pour reviennent à
l'équipe de france pour l'inconnu noms
de la première vague c'est à dire où
chacun va dans le même sens les
politiques comme les gens de l'intérêt
alors catherine small world c'est la
responsable des situations d'urgence à
l'om est europe a prévenu le virus est
avec nous pour toujours elle parle d'un
ennemi renault redoutable vous partagez
ce pessimisme le que le virus nous
accompagnent qu'ils soient là pour des
années et des années c'est tout à fait
possible seule chose c'est qu'il faut
qu'on arrive maintenant à le minorer
pour qu'il fasse passer de l'ifas partie
de nos vies avec le moins de risques
possibles dire qu'on va l'éradiquer
complètement alors même que c'est une
pandémie safar est difficile par contre
arrivé à écran
cette courbe pour avoir plus que 5000
cas pas pour est arrivé à avoir une
vraie politique de test qui va nous
permettre véritablement d'agir dans les
entreprises dans les lieux sanitaires
dans les écoles etc avec des tests
salivaires et en faisant ce qu'on
appelle le pooling c'est-à-dire test de
masse avec un seul réactif et si ces
actifs est positif on teste le monde
individuellement avant les tests
indigènes et rapide qu'on va donner aux
personnels soignants pour tester les
gens avec des résultats très rapides et
puis de l'auto test qui permettra aux
gens de se tester chaque fois qu'ils
donnent à une réunion à sortir des
musées barrières on peut arriver à
circonscrire complètement cette épidémie
vraiment à en faire plus que une sorte
de traces qui va rester là et qu'on
surveillera et qu'on arrivera à ce poids
a encore une fois à réduire dès
l'instant où elle pointera son nez
mais si on n'est pas l'oeuvre cela alors
là on aura tout le talent des phases où
avait confiné des confiné pour le filet
des confits les premières vacances ne
pas croiser pas quelques impacts et
savent pas en arriver là il faut tout
faire pour éviter ça merci beaucoup
jérôme marty d'avoir répondu à deux
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin généraliste et président du
syndicat de l'union française pour une
médecine et bram et puis toujours en
france les députés débattent en
commission la proposition de loi
relative à la sécurité globale un texte
loin de faire l'unanimité
il propose entre autres de punir la
diffusion des images de policiers une
partie de l'opposition et des
associations dénoncent une entrave à la
liberté d'information notamment sur les
violences policières katia technique la
nouvelle proposition de loi sur la
sécurité globale examiné aujourd'hui par
la commission des lois de l'assemblée
provoque la polémique notamment avec
l'article controversé sur les vidéos des
forces de l'ordre
on la doit à un tandem de député la
république en marche il ne s'agit pas
d'un projet de loi du gouvernement ce
qui permet donc aux textes d'éviter
l'avis obligatoire du conseil d'état
c'est pratique mais qui retrouve-t-on à
la manoeuvre pour présenter ce texte
dans les médias gérald darmanin
il défend dans une vidéo son projet
pardon le projet des parlementaires il
vise à renforcer les moyens des polices
municipales
le signe d' assurer les moyens des
agents de sécurité privés et de mieux
contrôler les images des caméras de
vidéo protection mais aussi debreu mieux
encadrer mais de quel encadrement
parle-t-on puisqu'à ce jour usage du
drone de surveillance a été interdit en
mai 2020 par le conseil d'état est en
ligne de mire on détecte le spectre de
la reconnaissance faciale
l'association la quadrature du net s'est
aussitôt insurgée
que fait la cnil dans tout cela
absolument rien son silence est
assourdissant alors qu'on fasse la
majorité parlementaire veut donner un
large pouvoir à la police pour nous
surveiller avec ses drones comme en
témoigne la ppl sécurité globale sur
laquelle nous reviendrons
autre sujet brûlant la question des
vidéos d'interventions policières
reprenons l'article est puni d'un an
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros
d'amendé le fait de diffuser dans le but
qu'il soit porté atteinte à son
intégrité physique ou psychique l'image
du visage ou tout autre élément
d'identification d'un fonctionnaire de
la police nationale ou d'un militaire de
la gendarmerie nationale lorsqu'il agit
dans le cadre d'une opération de police
donc si ni les live facebook les
couvertures médiatiques de manifestation
en direct par peur d'être attaqué en
justice par un policier reconnaissable
le porte parole d'attac a réagi sur les
réseaux sociaux
interdire la diffusion des images de
policiers c'est pour protéger les
policiers ou pour protéger l'impunité
des violences policières
la fille de cédric joue via mort à la
suite d'un plaquage au sol lors d'un
contrôle policier a également protesté
il faut réagir dans quelques jours je
serai privés de la liberté de diffuser
les images où l'on aperçoit la mise à
mort de mon défunt père mais le texte
aux allures de fourre-tout compile de
nombreuses doléances des syndicats reçus
par gérald darmanin extension du port
d'armes en dehors du service possibilité
de travailler dans la sécurité à la
retraite
pas de remise de peine pour les auteurs
d' attaques visant les forces de l'ordre
pas vraiment de la sécurité globale
mais revenons sur l'intention les
pouvoirs des policiers municipaux seront
renforcées mettre des pv des sabots
contre les saisies
remettre en cellule de dégrisement la
police municipale va monter en puissance
mais problème elle sera tributaire du
budget du maire qui peut être très
faible et de sa sensibilité politique
cette ppl prévoit aussi de renforcer les
pouvoirs des plus de 165 mille employés
de sociétés de sécurité privées mais
attendez les maires demandent des
renforts policiers pas des agents de
sécurité
même s'ils sont parfois commode pour
pallier les carences de l'état au bout
de la ppl une véritable américanisation
de la sécurité et non pas des pouvoirs
de police globaux et homogène était ce
vraiment ce qu'attendent les français
les députés pour la plupart de gauche
ont déjà dégainé 430 amendement pour
remanier le texte
et pour en parler nous sommes avec eux
alexandre langlois secrétaire général du
syndicat de police vigie alexandre
langlois bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france alors on le voyait ça doit
doit permettre notamment de donner plus
de pouvoirs à la police municipale
notamment en termes de verbalisation ce
qui réduit donc la charge de travail de
la police nationale est ce que
finalement c'est une bonne chose dans le
contexte terroriste actuel selon vous
alors vu le contexte pratiques sur le
fait de donner plus de pouvoirs à nos
collègues de la police municipale c'est
une mesure jasnières pratique plus
qu'une bonne chose parce qu'il n'y a
plus assez de policiers nationaux pour
tout gérer
donc il faut pallier aux carences de
l'état depuis des années est le meilleur
moyen c'est de nous enlever certaines
missions autour de nous décharger de
certaines missions sur notamment celles
que les policiers municipaux pourront
faire sur le code de la route sur les
stupéfiants qui lui permettrait de nous
recentrer sur d'autres missions plus
urgente encore l'idéal étant évidemment
d'avoir plus de policiers nationaux
mais pour le moment il faut pallier aux
carences il ya un désengagement de
l'état depuis quasiment maintenant une
quinzaine d'années alors la publication
d'image permettant d'identifier un
policier sont susceptibles d'être puni
certains y voient un acte
antidémocratique une entrave à la
liberté d'informer est ce que c'est les
terrasses aux longues alors le texte il
faut bien le lire le problème c'est
qu'il est mal écrit voilà il est très
subjectif c'est le fait de publier des
images dans le but de nuire et de porter
atteinte à l'intégrité physique ou
psychique des policiers donc en fait il
faut déterminer par avance le but de
pourquoi la vidéo est faite donc ça va
créer de plus de chaos sur le terrain
ensuite il faut faire les sanctions qui
sont apportées à ces choses là
c'est un an de prison et 45000 euros
d'amendé à l'heure actuelle si les lois
françaises étaient appliqués quand les
policiers sont harcelés sur les réseaux
sociaux ou par des vidéos
ces deux ans de prison et 30000 euros
d'amendé effectivement l'état bien 15000
euros deux mois avec les amendes mais
nous on est tranquille un an de plus et
enfin pour ceux qui sont vraiment
menaçante dans ces vidéos et qui appelle
à des menaces contre les policiers
les menaces c'est 45000 euros d'amendé
trois ans de prison donc en fait là en
minimise on minimise les peines qui sont
vraiment corps en attaque les policiers
sur les réseaux sociaux qu'on veut les
menacer par contre en minimisant alors
un coup de com un d'accord parce qu'à
côté de ça on nous dit que ce sera pas
fait pour ça et à côté de ça on muselle
le droit de la presse le droit d toute
liste qui a pu avoir comme bavures
policières qui ont pu être justement
expliqué grâce à des vidéos qui ont été
filmés donc en fait on est sur quelque
chose qui ne protège pas les policiers
parce que les mesures prévues dans la
loi sont moins protectrice de nos droits
et d'autres notre santé et à côté de ça
on muselle la liberté de la presse donc
en fait c'est satisfaisante pour
personne sauf la communication du
ministre avec quelque chose je suis
qu'il a dit à l'assemblée nationale
effectivement des fois des gens nous
filme à 5 cm 2 de visage c'est déjà
interdit par la loi on n'a pas le droit
d'entraver une action de police
la loire et plus clarifie la chose en
disant par contre n'a le droit de filmer
un policier mais at-elle distance cela
aurait été intelligent pour tout le
monde cela n'a pas été fait et monsieur
darmanin on se demande s'il a lu la loi
qu'il est en train de défendre parce
qu'avec cette loi finalement ligne ce ne
serait plus possible de faire la lumière
sur les violences policières qui ont pu
plus vers l'image finalement c'est pas
les images seraient toujours possible
mais le problème de ces images c'est
qu'on ne sera pas je prends un exemple
très concret quand quelqu'un vole une
pomme il sait qu'il a volé une pub
voilà il sait ce qui risque c'est dans
la loi le fait est avéré maintenant ici
on va filmer des images et le juge si
quelqu'un porte plainte va devoir
déterminer celui qui a filmé les images
et les a diffusés surtout si la
diffusion qui est répréhensible pas le
film et la diffusion était faite pour
nuire aux policiers hélas ce moment là
c'est très subjectif les interprétations
c'est la porte ouverte à toutes les
interprétations en fonction des besoins
de communication du gouvernement du
moment
si on a besoin d'envoyer un policier le
crucifix on dira ah ben c'est pas grave
on avait le droit de diffuser c'est un
portait pas atteinte n'était pas une
volonté de porter atteinte aux policiers
et au contraire si on veut faire plaisir
à certains tics à syndicats de police on
dira ah bah non à ce moment là c'était
pour porter atteinte à l'intégrité
physique du policier ou à sa santé
mentale
alors que j'explique a déjà des lois qui
beaucoup plus restrictive qui condamne
beaucoup plus ces actions mais qui ne
sont pas appliquées alors la
surveillance par drones arrête aussi
évoqué dans cette loi qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
la surveillance pare de rose qui est
amusant c'est qu'il ya une petit
paragraphe qui nous amusent et c'est
qu'on lui dit qu'on fera attention à ne
pas filmer à l'intérieur des maisons
il ya des grenades de police qui arrive
à l'intérieur des maisons je pense à la
sphère de madame célèbre et boyne donc
effectivement on sait que déjà les armes
ne sont pas qualifiés alors les images
ça va être encore plus compliqué la
deuxième chose dans cette loi il n'y a
pas de sanctions s'il ya une mauvaise
utilisation des images des drones
évidemment nous est en partie civile
dans la sphère benalla on a
immédiatement pensé on s'est dit mais ça
veut dire qu'on va recommencer la même
chose des images pour être sortis de
leur contexte utilisée par le pouvoir
politique pour camoufler des affaires
d'état est en fait qu on aurait voulu là
par contre ça aurait été nécessite une
nécessaire d'encadrer comment ces images
sans fait ensuite la deuxième chose des
drones qui vole ça peut être enlevé
facilement
enfin ça pose la question est ce qu a
été expliqué également par la quadrature
du net sur les manifestations
c'est plus pour faire de la m du
contrôle de manifestations offensif
plutôt que de pacifier les débats et de
pacifier les manifestations donc c'est
contre-productif à la fois pour les
manifestants quai pour les policiers
parce que quand les sur le terrain la
situation s'envenime et ben on est en
première ligne pour prendre les coups
alors la loi doit également permettre de
limiter la vente d'engins pyrotechniques
ont souviens c'est ce qui a été avait
été utilisée contre le commissariat de
champigny est ce que c'est réellement
nécessaire ça c'est une mesurette ça te
fait pas de mal parce qu'effectivement
si c'est autorisé qu'à des spécialistes
le problème c'est que la délinquance
s'adapte prendra d'autres matériels
d'autres armes d'autres choses donc en
fait la vraie question c'est pas de dire
qui a le droit d'utiliser du matériel
pour nous attaquer les délinquants on
trouvera donc c'est les sanctions qui
devraient être prises quand on est
attaqué quel que soit le matériel
utilisé
là c'était le matériel pyrotechnique
parce que c'était un fait d'actualité
mais si on fait une loi à chaque fait
divers on n'en finira pas et ça ne
serait pas productif
mettons les gens qui nous attaquent
devant la justice et qu'ils aient des
peines exemplaires ça ce serait beaucoup
mieux
il n'y aurait pas besoin de faire des
petites mesurettes de comme parce qu'un
événement qui a marqué l'actualité
merci beaucoup à les cendres langue
loire je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général du syndicat de police
vigie merci à vous et restez avec nous
sur rt france dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur la présidentielle
aux états unis avec un scrutin
beaucoup plus serré que prévu le
résultat reste suspendue à ceux d'une
poignée d'états pivot et on a d'ailleurs
appris il ya quelques minutes
joe biden remporte le wisconsin soit dix
grands électeurs un deuxième revers
majeur pour trump et puis retour en
france
les députés ont rétabli au 16 février
l'échéance de la prolongation de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
au lendemain du vote surprise des
députés ramenant cette date à la
mi-décembre a tout de suite sur rt
france
[Musique]
à l'époque il y avait une concurrence
qui était assez violente d'ailleurs
entre les russes et les américains alors
que j'étais destinée à voler avec les
russes mais une opportunité s'est
ouverte de faire partie du deuxième
groupe d'astronautes européens qui m'a
envoyé aussitôt à la nasa
et là j'ai une chance extraordinaire de
la nasa entraîné qualifié affecté en vol
comme un des leurs on est loin de la
guerre des étoiles à en est quand même
dans une espèce de con fraternité et de
solidarité l'exploration au sens large
est une activité en coopération
internationale où on se rend service
entre nations qui pourtant au même
moment son sujet d'embargo et de
conflits géopolitiques savoir est ce que
l'homme peut vivre et travailler dans
l'espace est ce qu'il existe de la vie
ailleurs
est ce qu'on pourra un jour s'installer
durablement sur d'autres corps célestes
tout sans le fait en coopération
internationale malgré des tensions
à la surface de notre planète
[Musique]
vous avez une situation qui de toute
façon va être dramatique ce sera pire
que la première fois même si ça dure
qu'un mois
de toute façon les conséquences seront
pires vous allez des milliers d'
indépendants d'artisans experts à qui ne
peuvent pas travailler et qu'ils vont
déposer le bilan même si vous avez des
secteurs qui fonctionne vous avez des
gens qui s'appauvrit en travaillant et
ça ça peut ça peut pas tenir c'est au
premier trimestre 2010 21 que on va
faire des cons et les comptes
malheureusement risque d'être dans le
rouge tous les secteurs parce que ils
sont en situation de crise ne peuvent
plus compter sur l'état et au bout d'un
moment vous avez un état qui déjà est
surendetté il peut pas de prendre tout
en main qui est va être obligé à chaque
fois de remettre la main au
porte-monnaie pour essayer de financer
davantage joué mais on sait que ça ne
marche pas on a une une économie qui est
réellement sous perfusion de l'état
enfin si vous enlevez la perfusion le
malade meurt
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
mais on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un en calant de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie de catastrophe
ça veut dire à côté
date à ce trop fine il ya un tournant
mais on recevait à vivre mais dans une
autre direction c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire de l'humanité que pour
sauver des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais plaint d'une décision
invraisemblable pour vos ça dépend
telles valeurs on attribuait la mort la
vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie redevient
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes même
individuel avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un départ
normal un débat éthique
[Musique]
une part de l'afrique comme d'un
continent en perpétuelle de son
dysfonctionnement actuel tient à
l'absence de redistribution à la
population par des dirigeants qui ont
une fâcheuse tendance à tout garder pour
les pays occidentaux ont favorisé cette
dérive en encourageant le maintien au
pouvoir de politiciens de plus en plus
âgés pour assurer la stabilité des pays
et des sous régions elles ont pu la
prétention de croire que les valeurs
qu'elle défend des est imposé par la
force dans leur conquête était universel
dans cette terre des possibles où
s'esquissent les figures du monde à
venir
il faut changer notre logiciel et
arrêtez de dénigrer le faire à
l'africaine en octroyant au management à
l'anglo-saxonne
[Musique]
à l'époque il y avait une concurrence
qui était assez violente d'ailleurs
entre les russes et les américains alors
que j'étais destinée à voler avec les
russes mais une opportunité s'est
ouverte de faire partie du deuxième
groupe d'astronautes européens qui
m'envoyait aussitôt à la nasa
et là j'ai une chance extraordinaire de
la nasa m'a entraîné qualifié affecté en
vol comme un des leurs on est loin de la
guerre des étoiles à en écho même dans
une espèce de con fraternité et de
solidarité l'exploration au sens large
est une activité en coopération
internationale où on se rend service
entre nations qui pourtant au même
moment son sujet d'embargo et de
conflits géopolitiques savoir est ce que
l'homme peut vivre et travailler dans
l'espace est ce qu'il existe de la vie
ailleurs
est ce qu'on pourra un jour s'installer
durablement sur d'autres corps célestes
tout sans le fait en coopération
internationale malgré des tensions
à la surface de nos terres
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas d'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie d'avoir un métier
[Musique]
la france fait partie de ces pays qui
ont mal géré cette crise je crois qu'on
ne pouvait pas échapper au confinement à
partir du moment où on n'avait pas su
anticiper cette crise et la préparer il
ya un point d'interrogation pour
l'opinion c'est qu'on a beaucoup
emprunté je crois qu'on pouvait pas
faire autrement
l'échec sanitaire en traîne l'échec
économique
c'est sans doute la dernière fois que la
france peut emprunter vert à 30% de son
pipe pour essayer pas tellement de
relancer son économie mais vraiment de
reconstruire un modèle est cette fois ci
nous n'avons plus droit à l'erreur
vous nous expliquer qu effectivement le
réveil va être compliqué il va être
douloureux il ya eu un moment de très
grand relâchement et nous sommes en
train de payer ce moment de très grand
relâchement
donc c'est bien parce qu'on a échoué
dans la gestion de l'épidémie
qu'aujourd'hui on est en train d'échouer
dans la relance
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de fine
stratégie peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire je suis allée de chômeurs et
chaque semaine dans l'échiquier mondial
nous analyserons les coups les plus
complexes du jeu politique
internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit ben écoutez vous avez de
la première femme qui allait rentrer
dans ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que si ben voilà c'est fini pour
moi est ce que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça dit majeur mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité sur n'est pas en
appartements ont énervé grenelle
sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément loin de
paris mais toujours moins de ceux qui
les dirigent maintenant vers mâcon il
passe un tour de tracteur et cnooc vivre
en campagne il faut savoir c'est qu'une
vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait t'aider quoi un
peu plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée
c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information
il est 21 heures heure de paris tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce mercredi 4 novembre 2001 donald trump
ou joe biden le suspense est total des
décomptes sont encore en cours dans
plusieurs états le président américain a
de son côté affirmé avoir gagné cette
élection en remettant en cause des voix
de l'élection
il dit vouloir saisir la cour suprême
dans le camp démocrate dénonce des
paroles scandaleux sans précédent est
fausse
joe biden promet une lutte sans répit
jusqu'à ce que chaque bulletin sera
compté le réseau social twitter a
également signalé des tweets de donald
trump pour désinformation
[Musique]
en france l'assemblée rétabli au 16
février l'échéance de la prolongation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
un nouveau conseil de défense s'est
tenue ce matin et la question de
l'instauration d'un couvre-feu en ile de
france est toujours sur la table
après un pic sans remarquer hier à
l'assemblée nationale
olivier ferrand a été auditionné cet
après-midi par la mission d'information
sur la gestion et les conséquences de
l'épidémie
[Musique]
la deuxième vague en italie dans un pays
déjà traumatisée par la première le chef
du gouvernement d'user paix comté a
signé dans la nuit un décret instaurant
un couvre-feu entre 22h et 5h il entre
en vigueur dès demain en fonction de la
gravité de la situation les 20 régions
d'italie seront divisés en zone verte
orange et rouge avec des mesures plus ou
moins strictes
[Musique]
l attentat de vienne revendiqué par le
groupe etat islamique et on sait on en
sait plus sur l'auteur de l' attaque à
l'assaillant a battu par la police a
tiré en plein coeur de la capitale
autrichienne avec un fusil d'assaut
connu des services de police il avait
déjà séjourné en prison est suivi un
programme de déradicalisation le
chancelier autrichien appelle l'union
européenne à lutter contre ce qu'il
nomme al islam politique une idéologie
qui représente un danger pour le modèle
de vie européen
emmanuel macron lui est attendu lundi à
vienne
et on ouvre cette deuxième heure
d'information avec l'élection américaine
est tout de suite direction les états
unis pour retrouver notre envoyé spécial
à washington stéphanie de mary stéphanie
très heureux de vous retrouver depuis
washington alors le suspense reste
entier quelles sont les dernières
informations
elles sont nombreux oliviers il faut
tenter d'y voir plus clair dans ses
rebondissements chaque minute évidemment
puisque les dépouillements vous l'avais
dit dans vos titres se poursuit 20
évidemment aux états unis les
incertitudes
elles sont effectivement très nombreuses
on va commencer par ce qu'on sait selon
les derniers décomptes le camp by john
là aurait l avantage avec 248 voix des
grands électeurs contre 214 contre
donald trump
il ya une heure c'était 238 voix mais se
sont ajoutés les dix voix des grands
électeurs du whisky n'sync aurait à
gagner
joe biden jeu libyen aurait parce que
donald trump lui n'est pas vraiment
d'accord avec ce postulat et le
président américain demande le recompte
des voix dans le wiz consignes
alors pas de surprise en revanche sur
les états traditionnellement ancrée
républicain ou démocrate
évidemment la côte est comme des villes
comme new york et washington sont
traditionnellement démocrate et donc
remporté par joe biden un peu plus de
surprise peut-être du côté de donald
trump qui l'a emporté au texas et ses
fameux 38 grands électeurs dans l'ohio
18 grands électeurs et surtout dans la
très convoitée swing states floride avec
29 grands électeurs ce qui pose problème
ce sont précisément ces états clés vous
savez ces fameux swing states dont on
parle tout le temps vous savez
maintenant ce que c'est parce que c'est
là bas que se joue l'élection de manière
certaine alors 5 et 1 sont toujours
incertains on a enlevé le wisconsin
depuis tout à l'heure il s'agit du
nevada où l'avantagé donné à joe biden à
l'heure où l'on parle le michigan où l'
avantage est également donnée aux
démocrates mais attention c'est plus
serré un dans le michigan 49 5 à 10%
pour by dane a priori 48 9%
pour donald trump selon les derniers
des comptes la caroline du nord cette
fois ci c'est un avantage à donald trump
ainsi que la géorgie où le président
républicain est aussi avantagé pour le
moment par les voies la pennsylvanie
très très scrutées 7 et aller tacler par
excellence pour le moment donald trump
est avantagé par les voies en
pennsylvanie mais attention attention
parce qu'il manque un million de voix a
compté ce sont les votes par
correspondance qui sont il faut bien le
dire souvent traditionnellement à gauche
je vous propose d'écouter tout à l'heure
le gouverneur qui s'est exprimée de
pennsylvanie écoutez nous ne connaîtrons
peut-être même pas les résultats
aujourd'hui
mais le plus important est que nous
ayons des résultats fiables
encore une fois même si cela prend un
peu plus de temps que ce à quoi nous
sommes habitués
ne vous y trompez pas notre démocratie
est mise à l'épreuve dans cette élection
ouais effectivement donc la pennsylvanie
où il va falloir être extrêmement
patient pour connaître le décompte de
ces millions un million de ventes mais
attention il semblerait en selon les
calculs que si joe biden remporté le wiz
consignes ce qu'il vient de faire a
priori le michigan et le nevada il
pourrait se passer de la pennsylvanie à
noter aussi une dernière information
selon plusieurs médias américain joe
biden qui fait qu'ils avaient été
annoncées gagnant en arizona ne le
serait pas forcément
donc c'est à suivre également dans les
prochaines heures olivier chose est
certaine stéphanie c'est une bataille
féroce entre les deux camps à coups de
déclarations interposées 1
oui je vous le confirme effectivement et
ont sans s'avancer à grand pas cette
fameuse action judiciaire dont on parle
depuis déjà plusieurs jours exemple
dernier exemple en date il ya quelques
minutes donald trump qui vient de saisir
la justice au sujet du dépouillement du
michigan
le président américain demande l'arrêt
du dépouillement l'arrêt du comptage des
votes dans le michigan où joe biden
enregistrait pour leurs quarante cinq
mille voix d'avancé sur un dépouillement
de 96 pourtant ce que pour cent des
bulletins
alors on va faire un petit retour en
arrière pour vous planter le décor les
hostilités elles ont commencé très tôt
ici aux etats unis ils étaient 2h20 du
matin précisément quand le président
américain pris la parole depuis la
maison blanche il a revendiqué la
victoire il a évoqué des fraudes
demandant de saisir la cour suprême le
combat et dan a aussitôt réagi dès que
dénonçant des propos scandaleux sans
précédent un job hayden qui n'est pas en
reste
parce que lui aussi finalement quelque
sorte il a déclaré sa victoire assez
rapidement se montrant extrêmement
optimiste sur cette victoire à cette
élection il ya eu une petite pause le
temps que les deux candidats récupère
des forces en dormant un petit peu et la
bataille des déclarations a repris de
plus belle ce matin avec des tweets de
donald trump
à noter pour la petite anecdote que
trois sur quatre des tweets donald trump
ont été censurés par twitter je cite au
motif que le contenu est contestée est
susceptible d'être trompeur dans une
élection donald trump en tout cas qui
s'étonne largement et c'est peu de le
dire que l' avantage semble désormais
tournée
al'avantage donc de son rival alors
stéphanie hier soir j'étais en tête
souvent bien parti dans de nombreux
états clés dans presque tous les
endroits dirigé et contrôlé par des
démocrates
puis un par un ils ont commencé à
disparaître comme par magie au fur et à
mesure que les bulletins de vote
surprise était content et très étrange
et les sondeurs se sont complètement est
historiquement tromper
[Applaudissements]
donald trump qui fait part de son
scepticisme et on l'aura compris qui
certainement va actionner la justice
s'est déjà fait effectivement dans le
michigan
joe biden de son côté qui dit également
ne rien lâcher et écouter ce tweet aussi
un job aydan nous n'aurons pas de répit
tant que le vote de chacun n'aura pas
été comptés soyez à l'écouté de ma
directrice de campagne
jane au mali dillon et mon conseiller de
campagne bob bauer qui font le point sur
la situation de la course
non je me reporte pas ok
être balayée par joe biden les
américains se sont déplacés en masse des
batailles et ils ont déjoué les sondeurs
et les médias sont-ils groggy
aujourd'hui écoutez il ya deux
distinctions à faire une distinction
plus tôt entre les médias et les
sondeurs les médias américains
effectivement pour la plupart les médias
dits même stream par donald trump
faisait grise mine hier soir à l'annoncé
des premiers résultats parce
qu'effectivement les sondeurs nous avait
annoncé une vague bleue 10 voix d'avancé
sur deûle en truck ça n'a pas eu lieu
quoi qu'il arrive quel que soit le
gagnant ça n'aura pas lieu en cette
vague bleue donc étonnement des médias
qui il faut quand même le dire était
resté plutôt prudent et eve avait appelé
les électeurs à aller voter en revanche
effectivement les instituts de sondage
eux pourront faire leur examen de
conscience tout comme ils l'avaient
peut-être fait déjà en 2016 mais
manifestement avec peu de réussite
puisque quoiqu'il arrive c'est la seule
certitude de ce scrutin c'est que ces
instituts de sondage se sont
copieusement tromper alors comment
expliquer cette erreur une fois de plus
on parle beaucoup ici aux etats-unis du
vote cacher ses fameuses électeurs
qu'ils n'oseraient pas dire qu'ils
votent
donald trump j'écoutais hier soir le
présentateur vedette de fox news tucker
carlson qui s'est lancé dans une
plaidoirie est ce que nous sommes dans
un état libre
concluons que non finalement autre
illustration la démission d'un
journaliste collaborateur de douar
snowden glen green world qui a
démissionné de son média il intercède
parce que tout simplement on lui avait
demandé d'être plus clément avec les
démocrates
alors effectivement y at il une censure
de la presse aux etats unis c'est en
tout cas ce que affirmant clairement ce
journaliste glenn greenwald peut-être
aussi de la part des sondeurs une
méconnaissance ou simplement du peuple
américain parce que quand on arrive à
washington m
1 on nous dit ici dans la rue on nous
disait il ya quelques jours en tout cas
que donald trump allait certainement
gagner alors il n'a pas encore gagné
peut-être pas mais on est loin de cette
vague bleue prédite par les sondages
olivier merci beaucoup
stéphanie stéphanie de muret en direct
depuis washington et sur place à les
autorités craignent des débordements les
précisions de notre reporter a new york
thomas bonnet on est face à un scénario
qui était redouté par les autorités
celui où les résultats sont contestés et
où aucun des deux candidats est en
mesure de revendiquer une victoire nette
et sans appel la situation pourrait donc
s'éterniser et les accusations sont déjà
échangés entre les deux candidats la
crainte maintenant c'est que ces
invectives se concrétise sur le terrain
entre des militants pro trump et pro by
then quelques manifestations sont d'ores
et déjà prévues ce mercredi mais il
semblerait que l'ensemble du pays soit
encore suspendu à l'issue de ce scrutin
particulièrement indécis et même si un
vainqueur était annoncée dans les
prochaines heures ça devrait permettre à
terme aux débats tant les écarts sont
serrés et en les accusations
d'irrégularité plane sur le
dépouillement les barricades
il devrait donc pas être retiré tout de
suite de des commerces new yorkais ainsi
que dans les autres villes américaines
les autorités sont sur le qui vive
certaines polices locales avaient
anticipé en suspendant toute demande de
congé de la part de leur effectif pour
pouvoir mobiliser le plus de policiers
possible si la situation le nécessite
et évidemment les regards sont tournés
vers washington où la maison blanche a
été barricadée ces derniers jours hier
soir déjà quelques antifa étaient
présents à proximité de l'édifice
présidentiel l'autre crainte c'est la
confrontation armée entre les franges
les plus radicales des supporters de
trump et de joe biden est une ville
cristallise particulièrement ces
craintes et la ville de portland dans
l'orégon le fbi a indiqué suivre la
situation
de très près il faut dire que cette
ville a été secouée ces derniers mois
par des manifestations parfois très
violentes
un signe de cette tension c'est la
chaîne cette chaîne de supermarchés
américaine très célèbre qui a décidé il
ya quelques jours de retirer de ses
rayons les armes et les munitions qu'on
pouvait auparavant y trouver et retour
en france à présent où la situation
sanitaire se dégrade selon les derniers
chiffres des autorités pour y faire face
un nouveau conseil de défense s'est
tenue ce matin à l'elysée de nouvelles
mesures pourraient être mises en place
dans les prochains jours annoncée puis
démentie par le gouvernement l'hypothèse
d'un couvre-feu à paris reste sur la
table alors le nouveau confinement est
il trop souple le couvre-feu est il
nécessaire place à notre décryptage
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
sébastien huyghe débuté les républicains
de la 5e circonscription du nord bonsoir
à vos côtés un joaquim pueyo maire ps
d'alençon président de la communauté
urbaine d'alençon ancien député bonsoir
merci messieurs d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors l'assemblée a
rétabli aujourd'hui au 16 février
l'échéance de la prolongation de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
hier les députés des diverses
oppositions avaient passé un amendement
fixant la fin de l'état d'urgence au 14
décembre
comment est ce que vous comprenez cette
cacophonie comment se fait-il que les
députés n'arrivent pas à faire bloc sur
cette question d'urgence sanitaire selon
vous joaquim pueyo coûté hier il ya eu
effectivement un problème ça arrive
quelques fois que la majorité ne soit
pas au rendez vous lorsqu'il ya des
amendements aussi important qui avaient
été déposés par les républicains
chacun chaque groupe s'est positionné il
ya des groupes qui étaient plus tôt pour
revoir ses conditions au mois de
décembre d'autres au mois de février
donc la majorité tout le mois de février
je pense que c'est tout à fait normal
que le fait majoritaire dans un
parlement l'amp hors de moi ça me choque
pas que le gouvernement a demandé un
nouveau vote
voilà parce que la majorité elle est
quand même présente donc voila mais ceci
dit l'opposition avait une autre une
position concernant les dates mais
cependant je constate quand même que la
deuxième vague est très forte moi je
bois sur les territoires de plus en plus
de deux personnes sont hospitalisées les
services de réanimation sont très
tendues et moi je pense aux enseignants
et je pense que le confinement me paraît
indispensable comme d'ailleurs parfois
sur certains territoires les couvre feu
si on nous démontre que depuis qu'on
avait ni couvre feu dans les grandes
métropoles
la tendance est à la baisse je pense ça
vaut le coup quand même d'y réfléchir
sébastien huyghe député les républicains
certains hommes 20 circonscriptions du
nord
effectivement face à cette perspective
d'une dynamique de hausse des cas de
contamination
quelle est votre position à ce qu' il
faut effectivement
et bien aller plus loin que ce
confinement que nous vivons en ce moment
est-ce qu'il faut effectivement que
l'état d'urgence sanitaire soit
prolongée jusqu'au 16 février comme
l'acte est d'ailleurs le gouvernement
aujourd'hui
telle est votre regard sur ce cap
en fait nous avions fait à adopter un
amendement puisque la majorité était
absente finalement de l'hémicycle était
ultra minoritaire ça voulait dire
d'abord que les députés en marche qui
était absent il n'était pas intéressé
comme il le fallait par ce texte qui est
important pour l'avenir de nos
concitoyens et nous avions fait adopter
un amendement qui permettait de deux
mètres de fixer la fin de l'état
d'urgence
à la mi décembre ce n'était pas pour
dire que l'état d'urgence allaient
s'arrêter à la mi-décembre mais
simplement c'était une clause de
revoyure comme on dit pour que le
gouvernement fasse un point d'étape à ce
moment là pour voir s'il fallait
continuer l'état d'urgence ou l'arrêter
parce que nous estimions que comme le
voulaient le gouvernement et il voulait
six mois tranquille sans s'en venir
rendre des comptes au parlement et donc
nous estimions que c'était beaucoup trop
long et qu'il y avait besoin
régulièrement de revenir devant le
parlement qui est le représentant du
peuple français pour définir et répondre
aux questions pour définir la stratégie
et et répondre aux questions des
parlementaires ce qui était somme toute
légitime
ensuite nous avons défendu des
amendements qui n'ont pas été entendus
pour permettre aux commerces de
proximité de pouvoir ouvrir dans cette
période qui n'est pas une période de
confinement une vraie période de
confinement nous l'avons vécu à
l'occasion de la première vague mais ce
que nous vivons aujourd'hui où les
entreprises sont ouvertes où les écoles
les collèges les lycées les transports
en commun tout fonctionne à peu près
normalement on ne peut pas considérer
que ce soit un confinement c'est plutôt
une restriction importante de
circulation qu'un véritable confinement
et danse
cadre nous ne comprenions pas alors que
toutes les entreprises étaient ouverts
et bien que certains petits commerces de
centre-ville parfois de villes ou de
villages étaient fermés il y avait une
distorsion de concurrence notamment par
rapport un certain nombre de plateformes
mon comment de vente par correspondance
de plates formes numériques tels amazon
qui eux peuvent vendre tout et n'importe
quoi à tous nos concitoyens partout sur
le territoire dont qui avait besoin de
remettre de la cohérence dans ce que
proposait joaquim pueyo vous comprenez
effectivement que beaucoup dénoncent ce
paradoxe donc à la fois d une hausse de
la contamination des chiffres en hausse
et puis de l'autre côté une vie je
dirais pas normal mais quasi normal on
peut aller travailler on croise pas mal
de monde finalement dans la rue
finalement ce paradoxe cela que beaucoup
dénoncent
est-ce qu'il doit être pour le
gouvernement doit finalement taper plus
fort avec par exemple un couvre-feu qui
a été annoncé je tiens quand même
rappeler que dans les départements
ruraux comme dans les villes moyennes le
confinement est respecté dans l'ensemble
on ne voit pas beaucoup de monde dans
les rues d'alençon une agglomération de
60000 habitants
je voudrais répondre à mon ancien
collègue je suis d'accord avec lui
lorsque il dit effectivement il ya eu
une incompréhension
parce que les commerçants on considérait
qu'il n'y a pas eu d'accueil une égalité
de traitement dès vendredi dernier
j'adressais d'ailleurs moi même un
courrier au premier ministre pour que y
ait une égalité de traitement sur les
points de vente entre les grandes
surfaces et les commerces de proximité
ça a été relayée d'ailleurs par
l'association france urbaine qui
regroupe les métropoles et les
communique belle nous avons demandé
également cédé qualité traitement en
partie on a été entendu mais la question
de fond qu'on doit se poser dans quel
dans quel endroit on est le plus
contaminé tous à la question qu'ils
posent pose effectivement quand je
regarde les petits commerçants qui
peuvent accueillir un ou deux clients on
aurait pu d'ailleurs faire une une
un dispositif pour permettre
effectivement à des petits commerçants
s'ouvrir et d'accueillir très peu de
clients pour respecter les conditions
sanitaires alors que dans les grandes
surfaces
vous avez des centaines de personnes qui
peuvent être sur un même rayon
donc c'est vrai il ya un sujet qui se
pose moi j'écoute et comme je suis
président d'un conseil de surveillance
au niveau de l'hôpital j'écoute
également mes médecins qui me disent
monsieur le maire la situation est très
tendue
il faut absolument favoriser le complot
le confinement est pas un confinement là
donc on a ces deux versions le
gouvernement a choisi une version
confinement en dix ans pour que
l'économie fonctionne toujours là c'est
vrai qu'il ya des contradictions
moi en tant que mère par exemple je n'ai
pas voulu faire des arrêtés pour ouvrir
les commerces parce que j'estimais cdd
d'arrêter illégaux
j'ai préféré faire un courrier au
premier ministre comme avec
l'association france sur belle pour
demander effectivement ils ont des
évolutions ya eu un premier pas le
ministre de l'économie des finances sais
pas si il tiendra parole mais je les
écoute il est très prudent et je peux le
comprendre a indiqué aux fédérations
dirait une re voilure dans quinze jours
j'attends cette revoyure
si effectivement on nous démontre que la
pandémie se stabilise
là où il ya effectivement un confinement
si on ne démontre que effectivement si
on ouvre les commerces
il n'y aura pas d'incidence sur la
pandémie
la réflexion mérite d'être d'être fait
et des décisions seront prises sébastien
est ce que il faut selon vous
aujourd'hui
taper plus fort une bonne fois pour
toute c'est à dire tout verrouiller tout
fermer les écoles les transports comme
au premier confinement finalement pour
mettre un bon coup d'arrêt à cette
pandémie
moi je ne suis pas spécialiste
infectiologues
je ne suis pas médecin et je n'ai pas
les chiffres en direct comme peut
l'avoir le gouvernement c'est au
gouvernement de prendre la décision sur
ce qu'il considère comme le meilleur
moyen de protéger nos concitoyens par
contre en tant que responsable politique
j'observe que les mesures que son prix
qui sont prises manque de cohérence
c'est à dire que à partir du moment où
on accepte et on considère que nos
concitoyens peuvent aller dans un
supermarché faire leurs courses
je ne vois pas la différence et le
risque supplémentaire qui existent
lorsque sur les rayons ce sont des
boîtes de conserve et lorsque sur les
rayons ce sont des boîtes des jouets des
boîtes de jeux pour préparer les fêtes
de noël
je considère que à partir du moment où
on les laisse aller dans des
supermarchés
pourquoi est-ce que chez le petit
commerçant dans nos villes dans nos
centres villes et dans nos bourgs dans
nos villages
et bien si un protocole sanitaires
strictes et mise en place pourquoi on ne
leur permet pas d'ouvrir et puis et il
n'y a qu'à faire un certain nombre de
contrôles et s'il ya un certain nombre
de commerçants ne respectent pas ces
protocoles sanitaires qui doivent être
stricte et bien ils se feront l'objet
d'une fermeture administrative
le problème pour moi c'est le manque de
cohérence dans les décisions dans les
décisions du gouvernement et on a vu
hier soir un ministre de la santé qui a
perdu ses nerfs qui a perdu pété les
plombs excusez moi de l'expression mais
c'est véritablement sur la quoi nous
avons assisté hier parce qu'il le semble
dépassé par la situation
tout cela parce qu'il ya eu un manque
d'anticipation à la fin de la première
vague
tous les spécialistes médecins nous ont
prévenu qu'il y aurait à l'automne une
seconde vague la seconde vague
hélas hélas rien qui puisse dire c'est
que nous n'étions pas prêts il n'y a pas
eu de stratégie mise en oeuvre est ce
que nous ressentons c'est que les
décisions
son prix dans la précipitation au fil de
l'eau et non par rapport à un plan
stratégique prévu à la vente
monsieur le maire le mot de la fin il
nous reste quelques secondes est ce que
effectivement vous selon vous vous
partagez ce constat qu de sébastien
huyghe que le gouvernement est en train
de perdre pied face à la situation
non je ne dirais pas au gouvernement
perd pied parce qu'effectivement le
gouvernement s'attendait pas à une
deuxième vague aussi forte
d'ailleurs quels sont les pays qui
s'attendaient 9e pas nous ne sommes pas
aussi fort voyez ce qui s'est passé en
italie qui s'est passé en espagne des
pays qui ont été très touchés ils ont
été également comme nous c'est à dire
qu'ils ont pas considérer y aurait une
deuxième vague très porte d'ailleurs y
avait des combines et plus vite que nous
d'ailleurs effectivement des mois de
septembre et beaucoup d'inquiétude
certains pays ont pris des décisions
dont je crois que le coc vide c'est
c'est un virus effectivement qui a
dépassé tout le monde y compris
écoutez moi j'écoutais des spécialistes
au mois d'avril au mois de mai qu'il
disait n'y aurait pas de deuxième vague
le vérisme repas mais quelques grands
spécialistes dont vous connaissez leurs
noms qu'on fait la une des médias
et puis on a entendu un président de
comité scientifique dire au mois de juin
il y aurait une deuxième bague lui-même
reconnaît qu'ils pensaient pas que la
deuxième vague aussi porte effectivement
là peut-être des comptines et trop
rapidement moi par exemple en tant que
maire dès le mois de juillet je vais
être obligé de vous couper est ce qu'on
arrive au terme du temps qui nous est
imparti en un monde de porter les
masques
lorsqu'on est pas le rendre obligatoire
mais j'avais puis cette recommandation
et je pense qu'il fallait effectivement
rendre obligatoire le port du masque
comme il rencontrerait plus généralisée
également les cours ce qui a déjà plus
d'un mois
merci beaucoup à tous les deux merci
joaquim pueyo maire ps d'alençon
président de la communauté urbaine
d'alençon ancien député merci avoue
sébastien huyghe député les républicains
5e circonscription du nord rester avec
nous sur rt france dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de la deuxième
vague en italie le jeu
du gouvernement use ep comté a signé
dans la nuit un décret instaurant un
couvre-feu entre 22h et 5h il entre en
vigueur dès demain
et puis direction l'autriche victime
lundi du premier attentat revendiqué par
des juges dans le pays emmanuel macron
sera sur place lundi
restez avec nous sur air france on se
retrouve dans un peu moins de trois
minutes
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit ben écoutez vous avez de
la première femme qui allait rentrer
dans ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que si ben voilà c'est fini pour
moi est ce que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça dit majeur mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
pour une part de l'afrique comme d'un
continent en perpétuelle de vie son
dysfonctionnement actuel tient à
l'absence de redistribution à la
population par des dirigeants qui ont
une fâcheuse tendance à tout garder pour
les pays occidentaux ont favorisé cette
dérive en encourageant le maintien au
pouvoir de politiciens de plus en plus
âgés pour assurer la stabilité des pays
et des sous régions elles ont pu la
prétention de croire que les valeurs
qu'elle défend des est imposé par la
force dans leur conquête était universel
dans cette terre des possibles où
s'esquissent les figures du monde à
venir
il faut changer notre logiciel et
arrêtez de dénigrer le faire à
l'africaine en octroyant co management à
l'anglo-saxonne
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde le saurait
pas en appartement on est énervé
grenelle sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
loin de paris mais toujours loin de ceux
qui les dirigent mois joseph mâcon il
passe un tour de tracts avec toutes les
campagnes il faut savoir c'est une vie
différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait t'aider quoi un
peu plus qu'aujourd'hui la france
oubliée c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit
jamais
[Musique]
oh
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
si vous nous rejoignez il est 21h30
heure française
l'europe durcit les mesures pour faire
face à la pandémie de coronavirus ainsi
la france a instauré vendredi 30 octobre
un confinement nationale l'italie à elle
décrété la mise en place d'un couvre-feu
à travers le pays
nos explications avec mélanie fort
l'italie tente de résister à un
confinement pour enrayer la deuxième
vague de l'épidémie qui frappe le pays
le premier ministre use ep comté a
décrété dans la nuit de mardi à mercredi
un couvre feu national
une mesure qui prend effet dès ce jeudi
et qui s'étendra jusqu'au 3 décembre
désormais les italiens ne pourront plus
circuler entre 22h et 5h du matin
excepté sur présentation d'un
justificatif professionnels ou en cas
d'urgence liées à la santé
le port du masque reste quant à lui
obligatoire sur l'ensemble du territoire
les 20 régions du pays seront divisés en
trois zones de risque verte orange et
rouge avec des mesures plus ou moins
restrictive selon le niveau de
vulnérabilité
durement frappée par le regain
épidémique la lombardie le piémont la
calabre le val d'aoste et le sud tyrol
devrait être placée en zone rouge selon
la presse italienne la réduction de
l'offre des transports en commun de 50%
la fermeture des musées et
l'enseignement à distance au lycée
seront mis en place à l'échelle
nationale mais pourquoi de telles
mesures
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
mondiale l'italie fait partie des pays
les plus touchés en europe avec la
france l'espagne ou encore le royaume
uni les autorités italiennes
comptabilise actuellement plus de trente
neuf mille morts et près de sept cent
soixante mille cas le 9 mars dernier
alors que la pandémie frapper le
territoire de plein fouet le
gouvernement avait décrété en
confinement nationale pour ses 60
millions d'habitants des italiens qui
ont dû attendre le 4 mai pour entamer un
déconfinement progressif
face au spectre d'une nouvelle vague
meurtrière bju cp comté a appelé sur
twitter le peuple italien à rester unis
et pour revenir sur la situation en
italie
nous retrouvons hume berthod giovannini
médecins chirurgiens une berthod
giovannini merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors peut-être pour
commencer une question sur le moral des
italiens comment est il aujourd'hui et
jeudi à quelle morale aujourd'hui il est
très contenue instiguée par rapport à la
situation française in italy il faut
dire qu'il ya un souci du fait qu'il ait
les choix sont beaucoup plus régionale
voit la gestion de la pandémie la une
lors de la première vague
ils ont cure mais on allait vers
l'inconnu et du coup il avait une sorte
d'aidé sur le karité nationale et terra
aujourd'hui chaque région parce qu'un
livre au synthé chaque région à
l'autonomie pour décider et les types de
systèmes pour on peut avoir c'est plutôt
conventionnel porte plutôt que tout
public et tout ça mais du coup la sava
parcellisé la prise en charge des aussi
des lumières émergence qu'ovide donc
aujourd'hui les italiens sont pas
convaincus par ce qu'est on a des
informations contradictoires
il y a un gouvernement de centrales qui
donne des avis mais après chaque région
peut avoir ses propres décisions
donc finalement il y avait une logique
mais nationale berthod giovannini
finalement est ce que les médecins le
gouvernement et même la population est
ce que vous vous attendiez à une
deuxième vague aussi violente
alors là aussi pendant l'été des
plusieurs sons des cloches parce qu'il
ya aussi ceux qui disaient voilà le
virus a disparu les leurs la charge
virale et les très basses donc on peut
retourner vivre comme avant il y avait
ceux qui disait attention il avoir un
deuxième vague des russes y circulent
toujours
et malheureusement ça c'est mon avis
presque personnelle j'ai pas ce qu'est
cet été on n'a pas trop fait nous n'en
dévoie pour préparer l'arrivée 2
de l'automne où on sait pertinemment qui
est tous les maladies respiratoires et
demande par rapport à la france
aujourd'hui on n'est pas encore dans la
saturation des délibérés a donc ça c'est
ça nous permet de tenir les chocs de
puisque chez nous tous les moments mais
l'autre côté aussi les soucis c'est qui
on n'a pas préparé au niveau on ne peut
dire delà des écoles des transports
comment tout ça on va préparer l'arrivée
de l'automne et c'est une deuxième vague
qui on sait pertinemment que les
pandémies
ils ont huit toujours un deuxième vague
de cette pandémie
et en ce qui concerne le matériel les
masques notamment matériels chirurgicaux
est-ce que
vous avez des pénuries où vous avez tout
le matériel nécessaire aujourd'hui non
concernant les matériels aujourd'hui on
a tout ce qu'il faut pour le moment on
n'a pas encore pénurie on a une pénurie
pour les blocs opératoires en début dé
de la rentrée autour de septembre
octobre on avait eu des difficultés à
trouver des blues 1 stérile mais ça
c'est ça c'est résolu je pense que
chaque hôpital crise et son stock l'aube
où les masses connaît pas de problèmes
pour les pour les tests en avant ils
sont disponibles la difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils risquent
d'avoir parfois des résultats qui prend
le montant parfois il est oxydé que
d'atteintes qui sont très importants il
ya aussi des polémiques aussi parce que
comme je disais chaque région y avait
six autonomie donc il ya des régions qui
autorisait les faire des tests aussi aux
laboratoires privés des autres qu'ils
étaient pour le public et du coup ça
aussi ça fait des bisous et paf a
simplifié le coup l'état des
réalisations des tests et les temps
d'attentes pourparlers pour recevoir les
tests donc mme hudon qui un peu cette
cafouillage sur les décisions en pas
centrale en tout cas le couvre-feu
décidé c'est une nécessité aujourd'hui
selon vous alors sûrement il ya des cas
qui augmente
après il ya toujours les problèmes aussi
et ça vous êtes contre audience aussi
entre les soucis de savoir combien des
niveaux des nouveaux cas on a et comme
les patients malades après aussi la
polémique c'est quand vous faites un
test chez une patiente qui doit répéter
le test chez acqua qui aura fait le test
il est comptabilisé comme a affecté
alors qu'ils studio la même garçon donc
c'est sûr que ça ça pose des problèmes
mais disons que j'en ai la gorge pour
les métiers ni thalys c'est le mac des
préparations pour le deuxième bague
méfaits qui on a mis des régions ce pour
préparer pour les trottinettes
électriques pour les pour les nouveaux
bancs d'école plutôt que prévoir
dati qu en dise pas plus toqué renforcée
est aussi là
la médecine de ville c'est vrai que ça
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup des
personnels de certitudes
les gourdes aussi acquérir l'amour c'est
aussi l'effet qu'il a plein des
patientes qui réparent leurs
consultations pour d'autres pas tous les
autres pathologies qui sont allés à
qu'ovide donc en d'errata diagnostic sur
les cancers du sel qui le présent
charleville 3 de la mène 10 à baisser
des démos des problèmes cardiaques
donc il ya tout retard qui s'y est dû à
ça à cause du chèque et pénétration de
son mii d'alico vide ou même du
personnel les infirmières y injecter
pour les personnes qu vide et du coup
tous les autres pathologies et sont
orphelines
merci beaucoup umberto giovannini
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin
chirurgien en belgique à présent en face
à une propagation inédite du coronavirus
les autorités ont opté pour un nouveau
confinement d'un mois si cela implique
bien sûr la fermeture de nombreux
commerces à les libraires bénéficié
d'une dérogation raphaël blanc d'amour
irait voir d'auxerre
soulagement pour les libraires belge
leur confinement entrer en vigueur dès
cette semaine handicap à nouveau
plusieurs pans de l'économie
en belgique les supermarchés doivent
même retirés des étals les produits non
essentiels et les exceptions se font
rares mais après réflexion les autorités
ont décidé d'accorder une dérogation aux
pourvoyeurs de livres qui ne cachent pas
leur délivrance on constate que on a
retenu la leçon du précédent au
confinement où c'est très bien d'être
enfermé chez soi mais quand on n'a rien
pour s'occuper
c'est long difficile donc effectivement
c'est une excellente initiative que de
dire aux gens que ce s'abreuver l'âme
c'est essentiel et donc ça c'est déjà
une super nouvelle en soi et s'est fait
surtout plaisir de voir que y'a pas du
tout le même cafouillage qu'en france où
pour le coup c'est totalement un
totalement absurde quoi de leur côté les
clients manifestent leur soutien et
souligner le caractère essentiel de la
lecture
je trouve ça merveilleux nécessaire
effectivement qu'on puisse reconnaître
l'accès aux ouvrages à la lecture soit
indispensable et fassent partie
effectivement du quotidien surtout en
cette période de confinement ou
notamment je pense mangé des enfants
adolescents
voilà leur permettre effectivement
d'accéder à la lecture c'est essentiel
je pense que c'est vital
c'est pas simplement que c'est essentiel
mais c'est vital obligatoirement que ce
soit pour les enfants pour les adultes
la culture la lecture quand on est
bloqué chez soi pendant un mois ou trois
mois comme avant obligatoirement lire
permet de passer le temps de se cultiver
on en profite c'est aussi un délassement
n'est pas uniquement c'est aussi
glam d'abord dessiné ce il ya des blancs
dossier éducatif une semaine qu'ils
restent calmes constatons toutefois dans
les librairies
si la nouvelle ne s'est pas encore
répandu massivement c'est tout de même
un sentiment de soulagement qui
prédomine chez les professionnels du
secteur et dans le reste de l'actualité
viennent toujours sous le choc après
l'attaqué terroriste qui a coûté la vie
à quatre personnes lundi soir dans les
rues de la capitale autrichienne
l'assaillant a été abattu par la police
il aurait vraisemblablement agi seul
contrairement aux premières déclarations
des autorités
le groupe etat islamique de son quand et
revendique l'attentât
les précisions de notre envoyé spécial
sur place nadège abderrazak el madej
bonsoir alors quels sont les derniers
éléments dont vous disposez sur place
après ces attentats
bah écoutez olivier le deuil et le
recueillement laisse place à la
polémique ici en autriche à les services
secrets du pays aurait été mise au
courant que l'assaillant de 20 ans
responsable de la mort de quatre
personnes auraient cherché à se procurer
des munitions auraient cherché à s'armer
l information émane du ministre
autrichien de l'intérieur en personne
brainwash une formation au cours des
dernières heures
des informations sont apparus montrant
que quelques temps avant l' attaque
terroriste
les services secrets slovaque avait
informé les services du renseignement
autrichien au sujet de l'assaillant il
avait indiqué qu'il voulait se procurer
des munitions dans ce qui a suivi
il y a évidemment eu des problèmes dans
la communication il n'a communication
est un chiffre égal les services secrets
autrichien était donc au courant qu'un
ancien détenu condamné en 2019 pour
avoir voulu faire le djihad
en syrie cherchait à s'armer sans avoir
été stoppé par qui que ce soit pour
tenter de justifier ce qui s'apparente à
un raté des services de secret des
service des renseignements le ministre
autrichien de l'intérieur a accusé son
prédécesseur est d'extrême droite
d'avoir agi est sérieusement dans le
cadre de ses fonctions
contre le contre les services de
renseignements
je dois faire attention à trouver les
bons mots qui conviennent à l'estrie il
va de soi que l'ancien ministre herbert
qui cueille qui est responsable
la destruction du service de
renseignement en autriche qui doit
maintenant être reconstruit et celui qui
aujourd'hui crient le plus fort des
querelles politiciennes qui n'intéresse
pas vraiment les viennois dans ce
contexte de tragédie nationale eux
préfèrent elles se recueillir et rendre
hommage aux victimes
je pense qu'il est bien du moins de ce
que j'ai pu voir aux informations que la
slovaquie a essayé de communiquer à ce
sujet avant les attaques
je n'en suis pas sûr mais il aurait
peut-être pu faire quelque chose en
amont pour éviter ce qui s'est passé
mais il est toujours facile d'en parler
après les faits
j'ai envie de vous dire que si quelqu'un
a envie de se procurer des armes il peut
s'en procurer n'importe où ce n'est de
la faute de personne les gens disent que
c'est la faute de notre gouvernement
c'est la faute à tout le monde mais ce
n'est la faute de personne
et si ce genre de personne vous se
procurer des armes
il en aura peu importe l'endroit c'est
peut-être une faille mais je pense qu'il
est trop tôt pour en parler nous ne
connaissons pas encore l'histoire dans
son intégralité
originaire de macédoine du nord
l'assaillant de 20 ans a été tué lors de
cette attaque terroriste après avoir lui
même assassiné quatre personnes et en
ont blessé une vingtaine d'autres lui
qui a donc bénéficié d'une libération
anticipée en 2019 et qui a réussi à
tromper le programme de déradicalisation
et les personnes qui étaient assurés
deux sont suivis à l'heure avant de
prendre de court incontestablement les
services de renseignement et donc de
passer à l'acte sebastian course a
appelé l'union européenne à se pencher
sérieusement sur la menace islamiste
on apprend ce soir qu emmanuel macron
devrait se devrait arriver ici jusqu'ici
à vienne lundi prochain justement pour
s'entretenir avec le chancelier
autrichien pour parler de la lutte
contre le terrorisme
merci beaucoup n'avaient pour toutes ces
précisions nadège abderrazak en direct
de vienne en autriche
mais pour en parler nous sommes avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales claude blanchemaison un
bonsoir merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors pourquoi la ville de
vienne en autriche a été visée quel
symbole finalement brasse en effet très
surprenant et ça montre bien que nul
n'est à l'abri une attaque de ceux de ce
type finalement un peu partout en europe
l'autriche se croyait protégé et de ce
genre d' attaque sauvage parce que elle
mène depuis longtemps une politique
étrangère tout à fait prudente
d'abord il ya eu le traité d'état de
1955 qui est lui garantissait un statut
de neutralité
elle n'a donc pas adhérer à l'otan
d'ailleurs ultérieurement elle n'a pas
participé à la coalition de la lutte
contre des ch
et puis dans les années 70
le chancelier crise qui a mené une
politique de bons rapports avec les pays
arabes en général
cela lui a d'ailleurs valu
l'installation du siège de
l'organisation des pays exportateurs de
pétrole dont le siège est à vienne
c'est une très grande organisation très
puissante qui ne contient pas uniquement
qui ne renie pas uniquement des pays
arabes d principalement des pea et qui
contrôle près de 50% de la production
pétrolière mais évidemment depuis
quelques temps il y avait des signes des
signes inquiétants qui ont qui aurait dû
alerter peut-être davantage les
autrichiens ça a été le fait que en 2015
et ensuite on s'est aperçu que vienne
était sur le trajet de terroristes qui
migraient à travers l'europe qu'on s'est
aperçu aussi qu'elle était sur le trajet
d'un trafic d'armes qu'en 2018
le chancelier sebastian kurz arrivant au
pouvoir a dû prendre des mesures il a dû
renvoyer en turquie une cinquantaine d'
imam et leurs familles de fermer six ou
sept mosquées il a également interdit le
port du voile et ico y compris
d'ailleurs à l'école primaire
et puis parallèlement on s'est aperçu
que 320 autrichien était parti faire le
djihad en syrie d'ailleurs l'assassin de
lundi soir était candidat il était là
c'était l'un d'entre eux puisqu'il a été
arrêté et mis en prison pendant un an
alors qu'il était sur le chemin de la
scierie un autre signe avant-coureur la
semaine dernière une église a été prise
d'assaut à vienne par une quinzaine de
jeunes aux cris de allah akbar donc les
lélés les signes avant coureurs aient
été là et en effet comme ça vient d'être
libre votre sujet les services spéciaux
autrichien avait des éléments qui
auraient dû alerter davantage les
autorités alors le modèle de vie
européen est il en danger selon vous
comme le
dit le chancelier autrichien oui bien
sûr le mode de vie européen est un
danger et jean sellier kurz la dalle a
dit à plusieurs reprises depuis lundi
soir c'est véritablement le le mode de
vie européen qui est attaqué dans son
coeur
les vielles noirs vivaient leur dernière
soirée avant le confinement
par conséquent ils circulaient dans les
rues il était attablé à la terrasse de
café des hommes des femmes et
effectivement c'est bien ça le mode de
vie le mode de vie européen d'ailleurs
l'opéra fonctionner pour le dernier soit
avant le confinement et on lit dans la
presse aujourd'hui que roberto alagna a
été lui bloqué par les forces de
sécurité à l'opéra où il chantait ce
soir-là bon en effet je crois que ces
terroristes islamistes attaque le coeur
de ce qu'est le mode de vie le mode de
vie européen
mais comme l'a dit le chancelier courte
il faut pas tomber dans le piège
le piège qui serait de les laisser
diviser les populations de nos pays
européens
et bien entendu comme il l'a dit ce
n'est pas une attaque menée par un pays
ce n'est pas une attaque menée par une
religion c'est une attaque menée par des
terroristes islamistes et c'est eux
qu'il faut combattre
alors justement l'europe qui avancent en
ordre dispersé face au co vide est ce
qu'elle peut justement apporter une
réponse commune face à l'islam politique
oui vous avez raison de faire la
comparaison avec le virus
le terrorisme comme le virus ne connaît
pas de frontières et on se demande bien
pourquoi l'union européenne en effet n'a
pas dépassé qui paie pour lutter contre
ces contres c'est contre ces zélés
contre ces menaces en réalité qui la
menace dans son existence même
alors pour ce qui est du terrorisme il y
à un responsable du terrorisme dans
l'union européenne
monsieur de kerchove qui n'a pas
beaucoup de pouvoir
mais on voit depuis hier des
déclarations d'abord de la chancelière
merkel qui pour la première fois un
homme le mal le terrorisme islamique et
il faut le nommer madame ursula von der
leyen l'après terme de la commission l'a
également nommée dans sa déclaration
hier de solidarité avec l'autriche et
puis dans quinze jours il y aura un
conseil européen probablement un visio
conférence et c'est ce conseil européen
que monsieur mac on va préparer avec le
chancelier autrichien lundi à vienne je
pense qu'en effet les déclarations ne
suffisent plus il faut que l'union
européenne prenne des mesures
ces mesures sont les mesures de lutte
contre le terrorisme pourquoi pas un
procureur antiterroriste au niveau
européen
pourquoi pas un parquet anti-terroriste
au niveau européen ce qui n'empêcherait
pas d'avoir nos parquet anti-terroriste
au niveau national pourquoi pas une plus
grande mise en commun du renseignement
puisque c'est par là que tout commence
et pourquoi pas l'idée d'avoir une
agence de lutte contre le terrorisme à
l'échelle européenne
merci beaucoup claude blanche maison
pour votre analyse je rappelle que vous
êtes expert en relations internationales
et c'est la fin de cette émission mais
restez avec nous à se retrouver dans
quelques minutes un peu moins de dix
minutes pour un point complet sur
l'actualité a tout de suite sur rt
france
[Musique]
oui
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont nous
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et d'un fonds talents de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté qatar ce trop fine il
ya un tournant et on refermait à vivre
mais dans une autre direction c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais une décision à vraisemblable
pour vous ça dépend quelle valeur on
attribuait la mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un départ
morales un débat éthique
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même